alors vous allez voir une carte à côté
de moi elle va fanni mais dans un
instant et plus il va bleuir et en bleu
foncé
ça va démontrer l'évolution de l'obésité
partout dans le monde depuis
soixante-quinze voyelles bleui mais
regardez ici
l'amérique du nord et voyez vous les
états unis le bleu devient de plus en
plus foncée en haut le canada et quand
ces fonds c'est comme ça ça faisait
qu'on atteint un pourcentage de 40 % de
la population qui souffre d'obésité
ici dans sept autres régions du monde
c'est l'arabie saoudite imaginer où le
pourcentage est très élevé cette carte
nous vient de louer m est loué baisse
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
parle d'épidémie rien - malbouffe
sédentarité loisirs en ligne et
maintenant l'étalement urbain
tous ces facteurs contribuent à la
croissance constante et surtout
alarmante de l'obésité que même au
québec on est rendus pas mal foncé le
canton dans cette couleur là on est dans
le 30 % de la population est depuis
trente ans le nombre d'adultes qui
souffrent d'obésité a augmenté de 13%
pour s'établir à 20% disent qu'on est
encore un petit peu plus loin que le 30
% mais chez les enfants ils sont
maintenant un sur dix à souffrir de
l'obésité
que peut-on et que doit-on faire pour
freiner cette progression mon affiche un
tableau 1 et chercheuse et membre du
comité scientifique de l'institut
national de santé publique du québec
bonsoir madame loin bonsoir c'est
alarmant n'est ce pas quand on voit ces
chiffres quand on voit cette carte
animée depuis 40 ans et même aux
québécois n'y échappe pas mais c'est
vraiment un problème mondial puis encore
aucun pays que réussi à renverser la
vapeur qui a réussi à diminuer la
prévalence de l'obésité et quels sont
les facteurs de prévu mais c'est
vraiment ce qu'on observe des
changements sociaux qui ont fait que on
vit dans une société où c'est pas facile
d'être actif physiquement et de bien
manger au quotidien on vit dans des
villes dans des quartiers qui sont peu
propices à la marche et au vélo par
exemple ce qui pourrait augmenter notre
niveau d'activité
oui on a plus de on n'a plus de voiture
dans par famille on l'étalement urbain
c'est ce que vous soulignez notamment
dans cette recherche ayant rien en vue
encore pour changer le modèle si je
comprends bien c'est ça qui est aussi
alarmant oui c'est sûr que l'aménagement
nos villes c'est une responsabilité là
vraiment repenser avec cette lunette
santé la messe qui est la complexité du
problème c'est qu'il ya pas une seule
cause est vraiment un multitude de
facteurs à considérer par exemple nos
milieux de travail
on a de plus en plus d emploi sédentaire
la grande majorité d'entre nous et donc
de repenser les milieux de travail afin
qu'on soit actif au quotidien a ajouté
un pédalier sous notre bureau par
exemple ce serait une manière de faire
mais c'est changer les normes sociales
aussi donc c'est vraiment la manière de
revoir notre quotidien il ya même des
gens dans certaines du travail qui avec
je travaille debout dans le trail
quotidien le monde tenait ces réunions
de boue alors sur deux j'avais vu ça ici
encore arrivée des nouvelles tendances
de réunions en marche alors seulement
deux personnes par exemple où il y avait
quelqu'un une impression de l'ours et
laval qui faisait cette année six
réunions en faisant du jogging
je pense que c'est un spécialiste
alimentation aussi du sud ils demandent
les conséquences sont programmées sont
les eaux si on prenait d'autres facteurs
notamment l'alimentation il ya eu une
hausse à lui quand j'ai vu les chiffres
hallucinants de la restauration rapide
bah c'est quelque chose qui existe est
tout simplement pas au québec avant les
années 70 on est rendu à quoi 8000
8000 commerces et établissements de
restauration rapide quelles sont les
conséquences de ce soit justement
particulièrement ce qu'on sait c'est sûr
que la qualité de l'offre alimentaire
qu'on le retrouve habituellement dans
ces commerces là et pas très
intéressante du point de vue
nutritionnel est souvent riche en sodium
riches en gras saturés ou en sucre aussi
et donc ça ne met pas dans des contextes
où on peut facilement faire des bons
choix alimentaires lorsqu'on est entouré
de ce type d'offre haut le nom ça peut
être alléchant c'est le cas de le dire
est ce qu'on évalue bien les coups de
l'obésité oui mais nous restitue voit
quelques années on avait fait un étude
du coup pour le québec on avait calculé
que pour deux mille ans atteignait 3
milliards de dollars les coûts directs
donc pour le système de soins de santé
mais aussi les coûts indirects liés à la
mpt l'absentéisme et l'invalidité
donc ça c'est première à chaque année à
la paroisse ce qu'on commence pour
inverser la tendance puisque vous nous
avez dit au début de l'entrevue que
n'est pas vraiment un endroit au monde
où je ne réussi à inverser la tendance
au québec on repart pas à zéro il ya
quand même beaucoup d'organisations qui
ont commencé à changer les choses
faut intensifier nos actions mais ce qui
est à retenir c'est que dans le fond est
les leviers pour changer les choses
c'est toute sorte d'acteur qui les
détiennent les municipalités on a parlé
de l'aménagement des villes mais aussi
les commissions scolaires l'aménagement
des cours d'école l'offre alimentaire
dans les écoles les garderies
donc il ya vraiment beaucoup de
personnes qui sont en mesure de faire
des changements
- parce que les l'offre alimentaire dans
les écoles je propose qu'on année avec
les machines distributrices mais fut un
temps où on ne ferait toutes sortes de
friandises qui à répétition deviennent
nocifs pour la santé la santé des
enfants puis l'évolution de la maladie
aussi l'apparition du diabète non ouais
ben salah le diabète moi ce que je
trouve vraiment frappant ces cas dans
les années 80 c'est une maladie le
diabète de type 2 qui n'existait pas
chez les enfants et même les premiers
cas qui était rapporté les autres
médecins douter un peu
la validité du diagnostic tellement que
c'était
on n'avait jamais entendu parler de ça
alors que maintenant à sainte justine en
une collection notre comité scientifique
et endocrinologue et qui vous voit assez
régulièrement non seulement des jeunes
patients que le diabète qui sont pris
dabio tic
donc ça s'est rendu une nouvelle maladie
est ce que en conclusion pour vous c'est
un sérieux problème de santé publique on
est au stade de l'épidémie il
oui mais il faut le voir pour comme la
montée des maladies chroniques en
général oui l'obésité le diabète et les
autres maladies cardiovasculaires qui
sont toutes liées à une mode de vie
sédentaire à notre alimentation
il faut le voir comme vraiment un
ensemble qui est alarmant mais qu'on
n'est pas dépourvue de moyens d'action
on entre madame loin
merci beaucoup on a fait une
conversation ce soir qui voudrait avoir
des conséquences sur la réflexion des
gens aussi merci beaucoup et noble loin
mais je vous remercie man soirée en voir